NAZMUL IDRIS: Welcome
to this episode of UXD,
where we will talk about Lean
UX, measurement and metrics,
and why they're useful to
making better products.
I'm your host, Nazmul
Idris, a developer
and advocate passionate
about design and mobile.
And Laura is back
on the show today.
Welcome, Laura.
LAURA: Thanks for having me.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Lean
UX is a way to apply
the methods of learning
as quickly as possible
and reducing the cycle
time, through what
is called the build, measure,
and learn loop, to UX design.
Practicing Lean UX
means that you're always
validating with users, that
you're designing something
that people will actually use.
It's about designing
products that
are both usable and useful.
Laura wrote a great
book about this
called "UX for Lean Startups."
Now measurement is a
big thing in Lean UX.
And last time you
were on the show,
we talked about different
ways of measuring things
using both qualitative
and quantitative research.
And you explained that
quantitative research
helps you understand what is
going on with your product.
And qualitative
research helps you
understand why it's happening.
So I have a question.
What does quantitative
research actually mean?
And what are the right
ways of conducting it?
LAURA: So the best
way to learn what
you need to know about all
this stuff is, actually,
to read a book called
Lean Analytics.
It's by Ben Yoskovitz
and Alistair Croll.
So they cover all of this
in a lot of great detail.
But I'm going to do
my best to give you
a quick overview of
the topic, so that we
can talk about how you can use
analytics to build a better
product.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That sounds
great, let's start there.
So what are metrics
and analytics exactly?
LAURA: At the very
simplest level,
metrics are the data
about our product--
how many users we have,
how much money we make,
what our conversion rate is.
And when we talk
about analytics,
we're talking about the process
of gathering those numbers
and making some
sense out of them.
NAZMUL IDRIS: I see.
So metrics are the
raw data that you
collect to measure key things.
And analytics are then used
to extract information or make
sense of this data.
Sounds like metrics
are really important.
LAURA: Oh, my God, yes.
So without looking
at key metrics,
we're just flying blind.
Metrics help us make
better product decisions
and understand whether
the decisions we're making
are good or bad.
They help us to make sure
that our brilliant product
vision isn't merely delusion.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That
never happens.
LAURA: No.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Yeah.
So now can you illustrate
why metrics and analytics
are important, with an example?
LAURA: I can.
So let's say you make a fairly
major change to your product,
like you redesign a product
page where you're actually
selling things.
How do you know if
it was a good idea?
NAZMUL IDRIS: Well wouldn't
it just look prettier.
And isn't that a better thing?
A good thing, I mean.
LAURA: It might be.
But what if it didn't
convert better.
I mean, what if, you
know, like fewer people
bought the product
after the big redesign.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Ah, that's bad.
LAURA: Yeah, it would be bad.
And it happens.
It would be even
worse if that happened
and you didn't know about it.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Oh, OK, I'm sold.
So metrics are important.
Now what makes a good metric.
LAURA: That's an
excellent question.
And again, it's
one that's answered
in a lot more depth
in Lean Analytics.
But let me recap here.
A good metric has to be
comparative, actionable,
understandable, and measurable.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Got it.
So what does that mean exactly?
LAURA: Sure.
So let's look at what it means
for a metric to be comparative.
OK, I'm going to tell
you that my conversion
rate for my product is 2%.
How do you feel about that?
NAZMUL IDRIS: I have no idea.
Is that a good or a bad thing?
LAURA: Exactly.
So that's the
important question.
Now what if I told you that
the conversion rate was
up 20% from the
same time last year,
or it was 10% higher
than a competitor
with a similar product?
NAZMUL IDRIS: Ah,
that's a good thing
since those metrics
actually made sense to me.
LAURA: Right, 2% is
just a number, right?
Two percent conversion--
might be good, might be bad.
It's impossible to
know in a vacuum.
But if you compare that metric
to the standard converge rate
on a similar product, or to
a historical conversion rate,
suddenly we can see that this
particular metric is better
than other similar products,
or this particular metric
is improving.
Obviously, it also works if
the number is going down.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Right, so that is
so much better than just saying
a 2% conversion rate,
which means nothing.
So you mentioned something
about actionable.
What is that?
LAURA: So metrics do
have to be actionable.
So let's take that same number,
right, a 2% conversion rate,
and let's imagine that it's
gone down in recent weeks.
That's actionable.
Specifically, the action
that we want to take,
is we want to understand
why it's gone down
and take some steps,
maybe, to fix it.
So based on the knowledge
that your conversion rate has
declined, you can take
that action to correct it.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Got
it, I like that.
So actionable metrics can
affect people's behaviors.
And now what else
makes a good metric?
LAURA: OK, it's going to
seem a little obvious,
but I like to just state it.
Metrics have to be
understandable and measurable.
So if your team
doesn't get a metric,
if they don't know
what it means,
they can't make
decisions based on it.
And if they can't measure it,
they can't do anything with it.
For example, I
worked with a team
that wanted to know what
effect their product had
on call times for call centers.
The problem was
they weren't allowed
to measure the amount of
time that the representatives
actually were on the phone.
So the metric was
inherently unmeasurable.
I mean, it would have been great
to know whether call times went
up or down with each new release
of the call center product,
but the information
just wasn't available.
So they couldn't use it or
make decisions based on it.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Wow,
that really sucks
that they're weren't
able to measure
such an important thing.
So we've talked quite a
bit about good metrics.
What would make a bad metric?
LAURA: I'm going to
give you a little quiz.
Let's say you create a comments
section for your product page,
and you want to
collect some metrics.
What are you going to collect?
What kind of metrics
do you think?
NAZMUL IDRIS: The number
of comments and the number
of people that left comments.
Those might be good.
LAURA: OK, well they're
certainly understandable
and, I mean, should
be measurable, right?
NAZMUL IDRIS: Yeah.
LAURA: Is it actionable?
I mean, would you
do if I told you
that the number of people
leaving comments on the product
page, on the first
day, was a thousand.
NAZMUL IDRIS: I have no idea.
Is that a good thing
or a bad thing?
Is that too few or
too many comments?
LAURA: Yeah, exactly.
So that's the problem with
metrics like that, right?
They're easy to collect, but
in general, they don't really
help you make any decisions.
I mean, a better metric would be
to track the number of products
you're selling on the
pages that show comments,
because you care how
much product you sell.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Right.
LAURA: You don't
necessarily care
about the number of comments.
NAZMUL IDRIS: True.
LAURA: I mean, if lots of
comments make people buy more,
you might want to make an
effort to drive more comments.
And if comments make
people buy less,
you might want to
get rid of them.
See?
Actionable.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Oh.
LAURA: An even better
number to track
is the number of
sales of products
over time on pages
that have comments.
Do they go up or down based
on people leaving comments?
See comparable metrics help
you make better decisions.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Now that
makes perfect sense.
So now I've also heard of
the term "vanity metric."
It seems that the number of
comments is a vanity metric.
Is that correct?
LAURA: Yeah, it is.
That's a great example
of a vanity metric.
And for those who don't
know, vanity metric
is a term coined by Eric Ries
to describe the numbers that
make us feel good, or sometimes
bad, about our product,
without actually helping
us make any decisions.
For example, the
graph of the number
of registered users
of your product
always goes up and to the
right-- vanity metric.
It doesn't help you do anything,
except possibly to raise
some money from people who
don't understand graphs.
So the percent of active
users, on the other hand,
that starts to be a
useful metric, right?
It tells you how many
people are actually
getting value from your product
and continuing to come back.
The percent of active
users over time
is even better than that,
because it tells you
whether your product is
getting better or worse.
And again, that helps
you make good decisions.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Got it.
So how about the number
of application downloads.
I know that a lot of
people track those,
and they seem to me like
they're a vanity metric.
They're not really
measuring the engagement
that users have with
the application itself,
is that correct?
LAURA: Yeah, they generally are.
I mean, unless you're
charging for your app.
What does it tell you
that a lot of people
are downloading your app?
You don't know if
they're using it.
You don't know if you're
monetizing them, again,
unless you're
charging for the app.
It doesn't really
tell you anything
at all about the user
experience of your product.
NAZMUL IDRIS:
Exactly, so it seems
that this is a trap
that a lot of people
fall into because it's so easy
to track these vanity metrics.
So what metrics should
people actually be tracking?
LAURA: Another
excellent question.
And unfortunately, the answer,
as usual, is that it depends.
But one thing is certain,
you should probably
be tracking fewer
metrics than you think.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Wait, what?
I thought metrics
were a good thing.
LAURA: I know, they are.
But only if you're
tracking the right ones.
So for example,
you should always
be tracking all of your KPIs.
NAZMUL IDRIS: So I've
heard of KPIs before,
but what do they mean exactly?
LAURA: Yes, so KPIs are
key performance indicators.
These are the
metrics that actually
tell you how your
product is doing,
and again, help you
make better decisions.
But one of the really
big problems that I see
is that, instead of
just tracking the KPIs,
just people track
all the things.
NAZMUL IDRIS: I was
actually just thinking that,
that if you collect more
metrics rather than fewer,
that would probably
be a good thing.
So what's wrong with
collecting too many metrics?
LAURA: So having too
many metrics is almost as
bad as not having any, right?
It's very easy to
start to drown.
Remember the goal of metrics--
good product decisions.
So when you have
too much data, you
can end up getting so distracted
that you can't actually
make any decisions.
It's why Lean Analytics
has a concept called
"the one metric that matters."
You'll do much better if you
focus on a single, critical KPI
that you want to move rather
than trying to track everything
all the time.
NAZMUL IDRIS: I see.
So that's actually the case
with so many things in life--
too much or too little of
anything can usually bad.
And always, less is more.
LAURA: Yeah.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Cool.
So how do I track
the metrics that
just matter-- that
really matter, I mean.
LAURA: Yet another
excellent question,
and why don't I answer
it in our next episode.
We can talk all about A/B
testing, cohort analysis,
and maybe even some funnels.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Cool,
that sounds awesome.
I can't wait.
So that's all the
time we have today.
If you'd like to learn
more about qualitative
and quantitative
research methods,
check out Laura's book,
"UX for Lean Startups."
It has a lot of tips
and tactics for doing
the right kind of research
at the right time.
Laura, thanks again
for joining us.
LAURA: It was my pleasure.
Thanks for having me.
Go build something awesome.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Cool.
Now if you haven't already,
please be sure to join our UX
community on Google+.
It's a place where we can
continue this discussion,
and you can meet
other people who
are just as passionate
about UX as you are.
Thanks for watching and goodbye.